so the question that we are answering
today and I'm treating it as fresh
because it is a new semester as lots of
people who haven't really had to
encounter this question before is what's
mascot to do with any of this okay you
spent a little bit of time some of you
spent a lot of time thinking about the
design process in a new situation and
how you're going to fit into it for a
moment just consider why these are
together okay science I think it's
reasonably clear isn't it you can just
say because science and that's enough of
an argument but actually let's give an
actual reason why right why does it make
sense that science fits together well
yeah we have like a big discovery right
scientists are the ones who are making a
difference okay
scientists are people who are announcing
the discoveries if you might remember
I'm not that long ago they'd say things
like oh we've discovered a new particle
new particle has been discovered at the
large hydro ah scientists of the people
who are excited about it scientists of
the people who it's named after right so
that makes sense okay technology where
does that come into it like think about
the Apollo program where does technology
come into that okay the rocket you're in
a spacecraft is loaded with technology
technology is what the scientists are
using in order to make their discoveries
right and then you go one step further
to say well once you've made those
discoveries engineers are the people who
take those concepts those principles and
then apply them so that we can use them
right think of something like st. GPS
GPS like this small little rectangle in
my pocket can tell me anywhere on the
planet where I am within just a few
meters that's crazy
and that's engineering taking advantage
of Scientology okay so then you think
mmm
dot dot dot what's what's the connection
where in this picture that seemed like a
pretty self-contained system okay so
here we go I have a big ID for you right
and if you if you follow along with you
notes which you ought to be he's my big
idea okay I would say like we would
agree the Apollo program for example
it's about kind of exploration going
places you know people say why do people
climb Everest right because it's there
right that's why you climb it you want
it's natural right well with regard to
exploration like we call explorers
pioneers right mathematics is the real
pioneer behind all scientific endeavor
mathematics is the true pioneer in the
sciences and here's my justification for
why there's a crucial crucial idea and
we're going to expand on that's what
this lesson is about mathematics enables
us to wrap our heads around things and
understand another manipulate them where
instruments and experiments can't go we
say that again because such a
groundbreaking idea literally
groundbreaking maths enables us to
understand things with instruments and
experiments can't go or at least where
they can't go yet and maybe they will
follow ok
mathematics goes first no I don't take
it you're just going to believe me so
I'm going to try and prove this to you
because proof I thought that you should
do right appreciate that
all right so to understand this right I
think the easiest way to explain why
this is true is if we think of these
three fields these are three things that
you study in school okay just
I would leave three that I'm going to
think about science history and we'll
get to mathematics last okay all three
of these in some ways all the subjects
that you do right at least all three of
these they just kind of will live
different ways to know what's true about
the universe about things around you
about events that have taken place right
and here's my question to you and I'm
gonna ask you to actually talk to the
person next to you in a minute my
question do is for each of these three
right being I think they all try to
answer that same question what is true
how can we know that it's true right
science history and math they take very
very different approaches to doing
answering the same question right when
we say something's inside typically
proven right or something about history
has been proved or something
mathematically has been proved
we know that it's true it means
completely different things for each
field so here's on the last unit
how did these three differ from each
other if you had to answer the question
science those things because of what's
the mechanism that it uses and history
knows things because of and it's gonna
be a different order okay so turn to the
person next to you try and write
something down for each of the three and
then we'll come together and share some
thoughts so let's say the gate with
science if you don't know if you read in
the paper something has been proven
scientifically what are you assuming
that people have proved it what have
they done to be able to claim I approved
this I've used science anyone to give me
a suggestion as concise as routine yeah
yeah fantastic city like okay I've got
an idea
I think it's true we'll experiment will
test it out and here's an important
thing right if a scientist came to you
and said okay I've tested something out
I did an experiment once and it happened
what I expected my hypothesis it
happened I just carry out the experiment
and it was like cool I confirmed it
would you say that's enough to prove
something scientifically no the answer
is emphatically no right what would you
expect there Missy yeah you can do it
over and over and over again in fact
that's really like on top of
experimentation the key is that you can
have an observation and you can
replicate it and other people can
replicate it right in a different place
a different time in slightly different
conditions but you expect what you're
going to get and you can get it over and
over again okay repeat the observation
and experimentation that's the way
science knows things
okay that's before history now I put
these next to each other because history
is quite clearly the opposite of this
you can't repeat history right like if
they're in the past you can't go back
and say well let's just see what happens
if we run it again okay
so therefore who wants to give me
suggestion how do you know something is
historically when it comes to history
yeah yep okay so you've got all these
like physical objects which can yeah
evidence yeah what would you add to that
yeah okay fantastic no question you've
got evidence so what what are you gonna
do with
yeah give it to the people who do
history yes Lee what are you gonna say
sure okay you're trying it yeah you try
to put together like some narrative
which makes sense of all of the art and
like you know things that you discover
and eyewitness accounts all that kind of
thing right in other words you're taking
all these different things which are
called sources right and you try to
analyze them get some meaning out of
them and try and fit them together in
one coherent whole what makes sense of
all of these things right okay last one
mathematics what we're really interested
in today it's different from both of
these it's different from both of these
how would you suggest how do we know
things how do you prove something in
maths any tankers divvy wicket okay so
we go we've got formulas it's like that
but let me just push on that because I
don't think that's a bad idea but how do
you know a formula is true like in a
right angle trying but it's like yeah
yeah yeah
do it yeah okay yeah okay all right
let's let's keep going on this right so
here's a room right oh this room has
this so focus it has a name namely
Pythagoras theorem okay these are the
three sides okay not just just ponder
for a second what would it mean to prove
that this is true using this kind of
approach scientifically what would it
mean you just explain to me how to know
something scientifically how would you
prove that scientifically yeah that's
right and obviously we know Pythagoras
to is only between certain kinds of
triangles namely right-angled triangles
so what you would have to do is you
would have to draw a heck of a lot of
right angle triangles and you have to do
it again and again and again and
hopefully when you've done lots of them
you could say haha repeated observation
I think okay but that's not what
mathematicians do right you can prove
this and you don't even have to draw
more than a single diagrams completely
different to the scientific method the
way that you know and this is the reason
why I'm I'm the expert to show you right
the way that I would phrase it is that
mathematics uses deductive logic right
when you set rules okay that's like
things are meant to fit together in such
a such a way that's logic and from logic
from a few things you know you can
deduce other things right you apply the
laws you don't need to go out there and
look for sources right you don't have to
do it many many times
I can draw a single diagram and say yep
without a shadow of a doubt my logic
holes does that make sense this is
different okay mathematics can be done
with just with a sheet of paper in front
of you whereas these you need like
apparatuses you need to go out there and
have a look at these things
mathematics differs in this way
mathematics goes where instruments and
experiments can't go right so I need to
give you some tips I've got quite a few
all right so so this is uh well it's
it's art its art this is from
interstellar right this is the artists
what they did actually mathematically to
work out what a black hole would look
like if you were actually a courtier
trying to look at it from a distance
okay now let's just consider this for a
second right told me what do you know
about black holes first it's why they
called black looks kind of white to be
yes so why what does what does black
matter okay there's this plot there's
some problem with white right what's the
problem with a black hole and like good
okay so we know that light can be
emitted from anything right and light
travels at a certain speed okay but
gravity could be so strong if you have a
super massive object but even light and
it's crazy speed can't escape okay which
is why there's that that black part in
the middle that like it's coming from
the outside is actually not inside black
hole it's as disc if hot matter it's
going around the lights being twisted
around okay
now being that light can't escape and
what is the fastest object that we have
right I mean I'm gonna break the fiction
for a second but if light can't escape
can you and me escape from an object
when you get too close the answer is no
okay the whole name from the phenomena
that talks about that maybe the event
horizon after you go past that it
doesn't matter how fast you go you can
go the speed of light and you'll never
get out right so if the speed of light
can't get out I take it that our fancy
scientific instruments and our
experiments also can't get out of it so
you can go in there you know any
experiments you like but you're never
coming back with the knowledge that
you've got right black holes what
arrived at by science they arrived at by
maths right we thought okay although we
understand the laws of gravity we don't
stand how wife behaves okay
mathematically it should be possible
that an object exists which is such
strong gravity that it does that and you
can never get away right does that make
sense you see how science didn't go
there
mathematics went there because it can go
anywhere
and in Sciences confirmed it we've gone
and we found places like a center of a
galaxy where like that we've done all
our calculations something in there that
we can't see it's you know in there the
mass is too huge this is the only
explanation that makes sense right
mathematics work first and in science
confirmed it by observing we've looked
at lots of galaxies and we've seen a lot
of things where it seems like that must
be there